we're heading into the center of a
mouse's brain into the hippocampus where
memories are formed
looking up you can see neurons
projecting to the surface of the brain
this is the work of Karl Deisseroth and
his team at Stanford University by
making the entire brain transparent they
were able to image it using a light
microscope they call the new technique
clarity
existing techniques for studying the
brains wiring are often limited to
looking at very small volumes of brain
or they don't allow you to label genes
or chemicals of interest the advantage
of clarity is that you can label lots of
molecules in whole brains
so how do you make a brain transparent
the thing that obscures the view is fat
lipid layers surround each cell to
remove them without disrupting the cell
structure the team used a hydrogel to
create a mesh to hold the rest of the
components in place then they could
clear away the fat this is a mouse brain
before and after the brain is now
transparent to light but it's also
permeable to molecules which means
scientists can add molecular markers to
highlight specific features
in this one millimeter block of
hippocampus excitatory neurons a green
inhibitory neurons are red and cells
called astrocytes are blue the technique
works in human brains - this is a chunk
of the frontal lobe of a seven-year-old
boy who had autism it's possible to
trace the path of a single nerve
projection through a forest of other
cells
you
when the team looked closely in one
layer of the cortex they noticed
ladder-like patterns where neurons had
connected back to themselves and to
other neurons similar abnormal
structures have been seen in animals
with autism like behaviors being able to
analyze brain structures like this and
match them up with molecular information
could help neuroscientists uncover how
changes to the brain underlie disease
and it's not just the brain the
researchers say the technique could be
applied to any organ
you